hello and welcome to this video one
playing tape be MC no hope it should be
five a-six okay I'm going for them see
three Sicilian okay here a six is
basically it's not entirely useless but
it's not the most pressing move to play
in an IQ p position okay so I don't
really mind the night is usually better
on c6 putting some pressure on before no
b5 that that won't that won't stand I
think so how do we refute b5 c4 or a for
many sis cups no development here yeah
and that cannot really work the thing is
how do we how do we handle at a forum
before this probably see form should see
to we should be seven it's not easy to
open this position really
okay that's good let's go with this not
totally certain but it looks looks quite
logical me this is okay from like I mean
I have a hard time to accept that but
maybe it's okay very ambitious
[Music]
don't really want to take on c5 so were
so soonish mmm yeah well why is that
possible what he's doing yeah that's
really I don't understand us
it's really odd really odd
there should be to 495 I don't know
strange
yeah 95 is a threat I guess
and she really was that the most
pressing thing to do with threatening 95
now
okay so the bishop hangs let's do this
threat night age for
create for maybe stuff 9h where's he
going actually night h4 Queen g5
just about
yeah I would like to totally refute that
stuff but I didn't I don't find a
complete refutation
so after this has to be okay right
this has to be okay is a completely
wrong way to phrase it when I'm trying
to say is this this is the best that I
can find that it has to be played now
because otherwise time time will be the
problem
so Luke's c14 a discovery or night b3
there's probably quints know that it's
not really good Queen c6 I can take play
95 okay here he cannot castle now
Luke c1 or doubling doubling problem got
19 seconds I know he has this one it's
super I got an annoying game somehow you
think this has to fall apart yeah and it
never did never did
threatening ninety-five
okay so ultimately it does fall apart I
just should be for crap no it's not good
I can take be ate the whole time I
simply did not pay attention to this and
I can take
take the damn rook on B eight knots
unbelievable
No 18 seconds
just to make sure that there is no back
rank made coming
that's let's pin no pin and win always
like that one
no trickery and the other one was a bit
clever actually
p6 and it's not a big issue how to get
rid of that Bishop Knight to c4 a yes
you know I couldn't I couldn't refute
this friggin opening and it looked
terrible really terrible like I have to
be five - yeah the engine doesn't see
all that much but only gives me a slight
advantage man so maybe it is okay I mean
it looks it looks dreadful having never
developing and so on but anyway so I
played c4 which probably doesn't really
do much queen age five five four found
very surprising I was really expecting -
expecting this remove and I'm not
certain like this I mean I mean my
development looks good but he's got this
one with the tempo and probably he's
okay and now yeah B should be - I
thought about that but I wasn't totally
certain what I'm actually threatening
that that was my problem here with the
smooth let's say he plays Bishop d7 what
is the thing okay so I play here and
then Bishop f3 is the problem mmm that's
interesting like here this is extremely
quick development that looks strong him
so that was an opportunity we should be
- as stronger than Bishop c4 I mean I
have basically lost the tempo there with
this Bishop c4 him and now Knight g4 I
went here and this should be some kind
of wind really so Knight age for Queen
b3 is doing the trick or Queen b3
immediately I had a complete blind spot
for for that this rugby aid is not
possible due to the bishop I mean if he
has to take f3 this position is a
I mean this is just over even d5 as
terrible now so that's that's better
than Queen a4 and somehow yeah it was
continuing the whole time so maybe we'll
see one is better but now it's the
dwindled away basically
he'll out 95 and yeah I'm totally
winning and no I simply somehow again
yeah I didn't have this on the radar
that it just take this this bloody Rock
no I mean it's so winning that it
doesn't matter but it really should take
yeah okay yeah it's just a simple simple
technique yeah but should be to where
that was stronger but I think it's quite
remarkable that this is okay for black
looks bad looks bad a4 is the
alternative but he's got this and then
there should be seven it remains some
yeah this is not so bad I mean I can do
this and then play b3 it should be a
little bit better for me but I was
looking for more maybe there isn't more
okay guys thanks for watching